uh what you need to know and there's
thank you nfl for giving us news on the
brink of the unofficial start of summer
there's news because next week owners
are getting together again virtually to
vote on
some rule proposals i didn't think they
were ever going to get to it but they
finally have and lo and behold with
replay review for pass interference dead
and gone the competition committee even
though it's not officially recommending
the sky jump sky judge concept the
competition committee is supporting
further analysis of an officiating
advisor there's a couple of proposals
from both the ravens and the chargers
that would create
something
that would assist the officials on the
field whether it's a booth umpire who
would be the eighth game official that's
the sky judge concept i've been pushing
for a long time or a senior technology
adviser to the referee to assist the
officiating crew now that person
presumably would have less juice than an
extra member of the officiating crew
either way they need to put somebody in
a position to watch what we watch on tv
to bridge the gap between what we see
and react to and what the seven people
who are trying not to get trampled by
the gladiators and trying to discern in
real time with the naked eye what the
hell is going on around them someone
needs to bridge that gap between them
and us and that would be someone
watching what we watch and telling the
referee oh you need to throw a flag
there or pick that flag up or there were
13 guys on the field or whatever the
case may be
someone who knows the rules
someone who has been on the field
understands what it's like down there
and someone who can then step into that
booth and see everything
via tv angles and contribute to the
officiating i think it's genius i
thought it was going to get lost in the
shuffle this year with all the other
stuff that's going on but it looks like
there's momentum for it and we'll see
next week whether it goes anywhere big
cat
i don't even think it's genius mike
because it's so obvious this is such an
obviously good idea that the nfl should
have implemented years ago and it
shouldn't have taken the uh you know
rams saints mishap in the nfc
championship game this is something with
the with the progression of technology
they should have figured out a long long
time ago the nhl has something like this
where they can call to a control center
and and decide goal or no goal the mlb
has something similar where they're able
to get on you know the headset here it
is so stupid that the nfl hasn't done
this so i'm not even gonna give him the
credit for for being genius here i'm
gonna say what took you so long and this
should have been the fix and i'll give
you credit mike florio because you as
bad as you were last year when you were
talking about we need to have pass
interference review you did say the sky
judges the fix you said sky judges the
fix and i agreed with you and it's
finally looking like they're going to
get there so i'm not going to give him
credit because this should happen a long
long time ago
in the interest of clarity and it's
quite possible that the new jacket fumes
are getting to you already
my position always was sky judge i never
wanted replay review for past
interference i mean ultimately anything
was better than nothing although we
found out that no nothing is still worse
than the anything they came up with but
the sky judge is what i wanted and i
give them credit big cat because in any
organization there is a natural tendency
to be very insular and to not give
credence to anyone on the outside and
i'm not the only one who's banging this
drum when you have outside forces saying
hey you need to do this you need to do
this the human reaction is to say hey
we're fine here we know what we're doing
you worry about
just like with sean payton to the
butcher you worry about your own
freaking meat i'll worry about what i
need to do and i i give the nfl credit
for not just walling off the very good
suggestion from many to have sky judge
but finding a way to embrace it if they
do one of the practical impediments big
cat is this
because they're not meeting in person
and they're doing this video conference
and and i somebody who is close to the
action told me this last week it's going
to be hard to come to a consensus on
anything because there's a certain
quality there's a certain value there's
a certain indefinable magic to having
everyone in the same room basically you
get everyone together and you slam the
door and you lock it and you say we're
not leaving here until we come up with
something
not as easy to do when everyone is
sitting at their house or at their
office or on their yacht with a computer
and they can check out mentally even if
they're still sitting there they can
check out mentally anytime they want
just wait for the damn thing to end so
it's going to be a challenge the fact
that the competition committee supports
further analysis is good i wish they
would go farther and say we actually
support this proposal even though it's a
proposal that came from a couple of
teams and not from us but i hope they
get there the meetings next week and uh
they have to do something because right
now it reverts to the same scenario that
gave us the ram saints debacle big cat
they have to do something and this is
the answer because i'll give you a
little uh look inside of the the regular
fans brain here speaking of as one
myself sky judge sounds futuristic sky
judge sounds like it's from the
terminator movies when you say sky judge
you say oh it's got all the answers it's
a lot harder to criticize sky judge and
also sky judge doesn't have a face so
when a ref screws up you know what ref
screwed up you know what crew screwed up
you know you like you could see fail
mary even though that wasn't the regular
referees in your you know it's it's
ingrained in your brain sky judge
is uh oh i'm gonna use a word here ready
for this omnipotent
judge is everywhere sky judge sees all
it's hard to criticize sky judge so i
will bow down to sky judge and whatever
sky judge decides i will take its fact
omnipotent is not nearly as impressive
as per severe which is one of the words
that you
you played out of your s.a.t preparation
book several months ago let me say this
i think that that the reason you just
articulated is why the nfl will avoid
that sense of omnipotence that's one of
the things they've been concerned about
they don't like the sense and fans may
resist the idea of this unseen force
that is reaching down from above like
god through the hole in the roof of the
old texas stadium and moving the pieces
around on the field no they won't use
sky judge and i guarantee you they will
tell broadcasters don't call it sky
judge call it booth umpire or senior
technology advisor there's a reason why
sky judge hasn't shown up and i think
they'll have a little camera in there so
if it's at hockey lee or some other
retired referee and this is the
expertise they need to tap into somebody
who's no longer physically able to do it
on the field but has the brain and the
experience you'll see the camera just
like we saw with the aaf and the xfl the
camera on that
booth umpire or senior technology
advisor but please don't call it sky
judge that's how i think they're going
to set it up wrong booth umpire terrible
senior technology advisor that sounds
like a job that a 65 year old would have
in like a corporation where they didn't
want to fire him but technology has gone
they passed their brains
they
machine back in the late 90s then
technology showed up and they're like
but we really like jim and we want to
keep him on so we'll make him senior
technology advisor even though he
doesn't know how to work his email
sky judge sky judge sky judge ten
thousand even add that sky judge ten
thousand
well whatever they call it there's a
chance it's coming we'll know more next
week i hope they come up with something
because my concern is they'll go back to
the rules pre-replay review for pass
interference and they'll just kick the
can one year at a time and just hope
there's never a debacle like the one
that prompted change in the first place
and
they could go 50 years before they ever
have another debacle like that so
because of the pandemic because they
can't get together there is going to be
a temptation to say we got bigger fish
to fry you know what if we have a
horrible call in the nfc championship
game this year that's a good problem
that means we've gotten our games in
that means we're on the brink of the
super bowl we should welcome a bad call
in the nfc championship game but big cat
the one thing that i said to you that
got your attention and got you behind
the idea that change was necessary
legalized gambling and when the dust
settles on the pandemic
states that were previously resistant to
legalize gambling are going to embrace
it because that's going to be a way to
put budgets back together and we are
going to see a proliferation of
legalized gambling and legalize
marijuana i'm not sure the two go
together but the more that people are
wagering hard earned money on football
games the more important it is to get
the calls right because it's one thing
to say my favorite team lost because of
a bad call it's another thing to say i
lost a thousand dollars because of a bad
call
okay i'm gonna push back on that yet
again because you don't gamble i gamble
what you don't understand is the bad
beats the horrific calls they put hair
on your chest they're war stories okay
they're like the rings inside of a huge
tree a sequoia tree that tells you how
old you are so while i don't want to
have bad beats i don't want to lose in
these fashions
i actually think in a weird way it's the
stories about those losses that are the
ones you remember forever so i'm not
gonna agree with that one holy i but
would i want them to figure it out
perfectly of course sky judge 10 000
will do that but there will be a small
part of me that will miss out on the
horrendous beats the horrendous
decisions and when those happen
they are stories that you will see you
will have in your brain forever duke
utah when they brought you utah back out
on the court i remember it it was
terrible those are the things that just
stay in your brain so i'm gonna push
back slightly on that point
but here's the thing and here's what i'm
going to push back on you you're like
captain quint from jaws you're the
seasoned old sea hag who's been out all
over the place and you've lived this
life and that's how you like it the
people are going to be betting are a
bunch of folks who decide they're going
to go get a jet ski and tool around on
the lake for the weekend they aren't
thinking of it your way they're thinking
of it as i got screwed they got a bad
call somebody needs to do something and
if enough of those bad calls happen or
if there's one really big bad call and
we see stories of the tens of millions
of dollars that changed hands because of
incompetence or worse that's when you
have to worry about the government
showing up with uh certain instruments
that get inserted in certain orifices
that the nfl does not want to have
happen
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports